House of the Dragon teaser trailer is out,
leaving many of you excited for what’s to come,
but also leaving some of you confused
about certain things, but don’t worry,
this is why we decided to make an explanation
video, explaining everything and more,
bringing some things to your attention which
you may have missed. First things first,
let’s explain what House of the Dragon is about.
It’s about a Targaryen civil war that saw the end
of many Targaryens and most of their dragons.
It nearly destroyed their entire house.
The series is based on George R.R. Martin’s book
Fire And Blood which covers the entire Targaryen
history in Westeros. The prequel series House
of the Dragon finds the Targaryen dynasty at the
absolute apex of its power, with around 20 dragons
flying over King’s Landing and Dragonstone.
Targaryen’s slow fall begins almost 192 years
before the events of Game of Thrones, when King
Viserys Targaryen breaks with a century of
tradition by naming his daughter Rhaenyra heir
to the Iron Throne. But when Viserys later fathers
a son, the court is shocked that Rhaenyra retains
her status as his heir, and seeds of division sow
friction across the realm. So, basically, the show
starts with King Viserys I Targaryen sitting on
the Iron Throne with Rhaenyra, his oldest child,
being his heir instead of his son Aegon,
much to the displeasure of Aegon’s mother
Queen Alicent Hightower. The real trouble starts
when King Viserys dies in the end of season 1,
leading to a Targaryen civil war over
who should be the next king or queen,
with half of Westeros siding with Aegon
and the other half with Rhaenyra.
But back to the season 1 events
covered by this teaser. First,
you can see Daemon Targaryen with a torch walking
through the dragonglass cave of Dragonstone. With
Ramin Djawadi’s music in the background, we then
hear Daemon Targaryen pronouncing ominous words:
“Gods. Kings.Fire. And Blood. Dreams didn’t make
us kings, dragons did.”, referring to Aegon the
Conqueror’s dream to conquer the Seven Kingdoms
as well as about Daenys’ dream to escape Valyria.
As he speaks, you see a succession of quick
shots: Daemon and older version of Rhaenyra
Targaryen on Driftmark shore. These two, uncle
and niece who eventually become husband and wife,
are the main characters in the series.
Next is Aegon the Conqueror’s dragon - Balerion
the Black Dread’s skull. The dragon recently died
of old age with King Viserys himself being his
last rider. This is his resting place. Then you
see a shot of the Hand of the King. It’s Ser Otto
Hightower. Besides being hand to King Viserys,
he is also the father of the king’s wife, Queen
Alicent Hightower who we later see with a dagger.
It’s the very same dagger that Arya used to kill
the Night King 200 years after. As you can see,
Alicent is in distress, caused by this very same
dagger that was used by Rhaenyra’s child against
Alicent’s child. When Prince Aemond Targaryen
attempted to ride Vhagar, one of House Targaryen's
dragons, he was confronted by Rhaenyra’s children.
Aemond broke the nose of five-year-old Luke, who
eventually took out Aemond's eye with his dagger
and here’s his mother Alicent
demanding justice from King Viserys,
demanding an eye for an eye. This puts King
Viserys in a hard spot as Aemond is his son,
but Lucerys is his grandson. Behind Alicent
you can see two members of the Kingsguard,
one being Ser Harrold Westerling and the other
being Ser Criston Cole, he himself becoming
major Alicent’s supporter after falling off with
Princess Rhaenyra. Speaking of the King Viserys,
here you have a shot of him sitting on the
Iron Throne with a Targaryen ring on his finger
as he holds Blackfyre, one of two of House
Targaryen’s ancestral Valyrian steel swords.
If you look closely you’ll notice that he is
also equipped with a Valyrian steel dagger,
the same dagger we just saw in Alicent’s
hand. Before it ended up in Alicent’s hand,
King Viserys gave it to his grandson Lucerys
as a gift who then attacked his son with it.
Back to the sword. Blackfyre is the
sword wielded by Aegon the Conqueror
which was passed down from king to king
and finally you see it in its full glory.
It ‘s got the crossguard fashioned as a pair of
dragon heads with dragon wings. At its pummel
you can see Seven Pointed star, a decoration that
did not exist when Aegon the Conqueror wielded it
but was added by King Jaehaerys, the symbol
of the King being the defender of the faith.
There you can also see young Rhaenyra who
is appointed by her father to be his heir.
Followed by a shot of older Rhaenyra
who is accompanied by Daemon Targaryen,
this time she is not at King’s Landing
where she used to be when she was younger.
She is now at Driftmark, the seat of House
Velaryon, attending the funeral of Daemon’s
second wife. Both of them are visibly sad as it
was Daemon’s wife and Rhaenyra’s good friend.
Then you see a fight scene that takes place
earlier in the story, between Daemon and Criston
Cole, giving you the first look at Targaryen
armor, helmet, shield as well as Dark Sister,
a famous sword of House Targaryen once wielded
by Aegon the Conqueror’s sister Visenya.
Dark Sister has the crossguard fashioned as a
pair of dragon wings with a head being at the
base of the blade. Daemon wears the dragon helm,
the same one Rhaegar wore at the Trident when he
fought Robert Baratheon. The armor is also the
same except Rhaegar had rubies attached to it.
His opponent Criston Cole is an exceptionally
skilled warrior, himself along with Daemon being
the best warriors of this time, and Criston
is particularly skilled with his morningstar
which you can see here as well. It’s the
tourney for King Viserys I's accession
where in the final fight Ser Criston Cole fights
his final opponent Prince Daemon Targaryen
and actually wins by knocking aside Daemon’s Dark
Sister with his morningstar. He then gives the
victor's laurel to young Princess Rhaenyra
Targaryen. Criston subsequently becomes a
favorite at court and joins the Kingsguard. Next
up is Corlys Velaryon, known as the Sea Snake,
a fabled Lord of the Tides, Master of Driftmark,
and the head of House Velaryon who comes from
the old Valyria much like Targaryens. He’s one of
Rhaenyra’s supporters and a good friend of Daemon,
having one child married to Rhaenyra and the other
to Daemon. He himself is the husband of Princess
Rhaenys Targaryen and here you see a shot of the
Velaryon family entering the Iron Throne room,
looking rich and powerful as they truly are.
On the left is Sea Snake’s nephew Ser Vaemond,
the older lady is his wife Rhaenys Targaryen known
as the Queen that never was and the other two are
his children, Laenor and Laena. You can also see
more of Velaryons in the background. They are
arriving here because the Sea Snake’s son, Laenor,
is being married to the King’s daughter, Rhaenyra,
and this is their wedding feast. You can see both
Targaryen and Velaryon flags hanging behind them,
with all the important lords and ladies
attending the feast. To avoid confusion,
Rhaenys has silver hair instead of black which she
has in the books, indicating she has a Valyrian
look and is a Targaryen, while Mysaria has black
hair instead of white as she does in the books,
making it clear she’s not of Valyrian descent.
She’s a dancer from Lys who became the paramour
of Prince Daemon Targaryen and the unofficial
mistress of whisperers to Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen
during the Dance of the Dragons. Then we
have another tourney where you can see
all sorts of banners including House Stark and
House Lannister. This is a great tourney on the
fifth anniversary of King Viserys I and Queen
Alicent's marriage at King's Landing. The reason
you see Tarly banners on the wall is because Ser
Criston Cole is fighting a Tarly in this round.
It’s during the opening feast of this very same
tourney that Queen Alicent wore a green gown,
while Princess Rhaenyra dressed in the red
and black of House Targaryen. Note was taken,
and thereafter it became the custom to refer to
"greens" and "blacks" when talking of the queen's
party and the party of the princess, respectively.
Prince Daemon Targaryen returns to King's Landing
as King during this tourney from his wars at
the Stepstones to swear fealty to his brother,
King Viserys I Targaryen. This little shot
is of Ser Criston Cole unhorsing Tarly.
Then you have another fighting scene, this
time between the Sea Snake’s son, Laenor
and Laenor’s friend and lover Ser Qarl Correy,
which will not go well to say the least. Young
Rhaenyra is then visiting her father King Viserys
where you see a new version of the Iron Throne.
It’s not exactly all new as the chair itself
remains the same, but it’s surrounded by new
swords, making it look a little bit closer
to what the Iron Throne looks in the books.
In order to stay true to the look the Iron
Throne had in Game of Thrones, but also get
a little closer to the look the Iron Throne has
in the books, it’s been decided to add the swords
around the throne, thus making it a bit closer
to the books. The swords that were once wielded
against Aegon the Conqueror are now defending the
Targaryen kings on the throne. This is where we
come to an end, but before we end it, I would just
like to reveal to you that the filming of season 1
is still ongoing and will be finished next month,
when it enters post production and soon after
airs on HBO. All of this and more you will see in
2022 on HBO. Thank you so much for watching. If
you enjoyed this video please give it a big thumbs
up and I hope to see you in the next one, peace!